♪ ♪
- GIVE YOURSELF UP, CARLO.
- [echoing spookily]
WHY WOULD I DO THAT,
DETECTIVE,
WHEN I HAVE THE UPPER HAND?
[laughing evilly]
- GIVE YOURSELF UP, CARLO.
- I'M RIGHT HERE,
DETECTIVE.
[laughing evilly]
- DAMN IT.
[gasps]
- OR AM I OVER HERE,
DETECTIVE?
- [yells]
♪ ♪
- OR HERE?
[laughing evilly]
- [panting]
OH, YOU SICK SON OF A BITCH,
WHERE THE HELL ARE YOU?
HUH?
[gasps]
YOU SON OF A BITCH,
COME OUT!
- DOES MY ASS LOOK BIG
IN THIS JUMPSUIT?
[laughing evilly]
- DAMN IT.
[music intensifying]
♪ ♪
ENOUGH OF THE GAMES, CARLO.
- THE GAMES ARE JUST BEGINNING,
DETECTIVE.
[laughing evilly]
MIRROR, MIRROR,
ON THE WALL...
[chuckles]
WHO'S THE FAIREST OF THEM--
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
- DON'T MOVE.
YOU ARE UNDER ARREST
FOR THE MURDER OF MARY DEELY,
MEG FOSTER,
AND ONE DETECTIVE
MASON JIMENEZ.
NOW, WHERE'S THE GIRL?
- OH, DETECTIVE,
YOU ASSUME IT'S THE REAL ME
STANDING IN FRONT OF YOU,
BUT MAYBE THAT'S JUST WHAT
I WANT YOU TO THIN-K.
WHEN IN REALITY,
THE RE-AL ME
IS SAFE IN A HIDING SPAH-AH--
AH-AH.
- OKAY, THAT'S THE REAL YOU,
ALL RIGHT.
- OR MAYBE I'M OVER HERE.
- NO, NO,
YOU'RE NOT OVER THERE.
CARLO, I'M ONLY GONNA
ASK YOU ONE MORE TIME.
WHERE IS THE GIRL?
- GO AHEAD AND SHOOT,
DETECTIVE.
[chuckles]
I MEAN, WHAT DO I CARE IF YOU
GET SEVEN YEARS BAD LUCK--
[gun cocks]
OKAY.
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT SAFE
TO KEEP A GUN COCKED LIKE THAT,
EVEN IF YOU ARE JUST
POINTING IT AT A MIRROR.
- TURN AROUND AND PUT
YOUR HANDS ON YOUR HEAD.
- NOW, FOR THAT,
YOU REALLY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO FIND THE REAL ME.
- OH, MY GOD,
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
[gunshot]
- [groaning]
PSHHT!
- WHAT?
- WHY WOULD YOU SHOOT
A MIRROR?
- CARLO, IT'S YOU.
I'M HOLDING YOUR LAPEL.
NOW, YOU'RE DONE.
IT'S OVER.
- YOU'RE GONNA CUT YOUR HAND
ON THAT BROKEN MIRROR.
[gun cocks]
- WHERE IS SHE?
- JUST SAY IT, DUDE.
- SAY WHAT?
- SAY YOU DON'T KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS THE REAL ME OR JUST
A REFLECTION IN A MIRROR.
- REALLY?
- I'LL TELL YOU WHERE SHE IS.
- OKAY, I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THE YOU
I'M HOLDING ON TO
IS REALLY YOU...
- OR THE REFLECTION
IN A MIRROR.
- OR A REFLECTION
IN THE MIRROR.
- MM, ALL THERE WAS TO IT.
SHE'S UNDER THE FLOORBOARDS
BY THE ENTRANCE.
OH.
[groaning]
I WIN, DETECTIVE.
[laughing bleakly]
I TOLD YOU, BUT--
I MEAN, THE MIRROR TOLD YOU,
BUT, WELL, YOU KNOW.
OH, FUCK.